hello everyone how are you guys I'll do
a hope you guys are having a wonderful
day today we were here with another
money-making method ah this is I don't
know if it's really popularized but it
actually does have a lot of requirements
so to make good money and also train a
skill you're obviously going to need to
have pretty decent requirements it also
requires a pretty hefty cash bag I guess
you could do it with less however you
just won't be able to do it as much in
bulk and yeah I'm going to go get into
the money making method now alright so
we're going to start with as you can see
here rube molds and onyx bolts and
actually this is the only thing we're
doing I don't know I'm saying start with
it but basically the requirement that
you're going to need is 73 I believe 73
fluttering let's go down it is 73 indeed
and you're gonna need a decent amount of
money for me to get a thousand of these
it cost me around 8 mil so I'm going to
go ahead and craft a thousand of them
and you guys can gotta get an idea as
far as to what this is good for I mean
realistically if you have the money and
you the figures you have to merge these
yet you can't it's to buy you have to
buy the sell prices and then sell it to
buy price so it takes it's it's pretty
much like Mirchi and so it does take a
little bit of time to do but you can
always just do a different skill on the
side while you do this so basically I'm
going to start a timer to see how well
it takes me to do a thousand of these
how many I could do an hour and kind of
the GP and I spirits that you would you
know expect to receive I would imagine
alright so coming in on the final home
stretch and it took me about 2 minutes
and 20 seconds to do a thousand of these
so I'll get a little bit of math on that
for you guys right now alright so as you
can see I bought the Onyx bolt tips for
8.6 KH and arune ight Bulls for 140 GP
so whatever we go down here we can see
what I bought an onyx bolt for earlier
that was eight point eight K which
leaves us about a sixty GP margin or so
and I don't even think that this is this
good of a time but it leaves us a sixty
GP margin in which we can make money off
of this so by that estimate that would
mean that I made sixty K in the matter
of a little over two minutes which if
you do that in an hour's time I got that
this method is around 1.5 mil an hour
which is insane you should be fletching
about 20
kay bolts per hour which also equals out
to 241 K Fletcher exp now there are
obviously like stuff that's going to
hold you back from this and that it's
the amount of money and how long it
takes to buy and sell this stuff so I
understand I understand trust me I get
it this isn't something that's like just
flush you logs and you make this much I
think you make 1.5 mil hour it's
obviously going to be very limited so
it's more like just spend whatever your
bank is whatever money you have laying
around spend that and do it as a daily
or hourly or every other hour activity
and eventually it'll add up and won't
take up that much of your time
so nonetheless hope this video was
helpful for you guys if you guys enjoyed
it feel free to hit that like button I'm
sorry that I'm sick but if there's
anything else I could improve upon hit
me up in the comments down below if you
guys really enjoyed the video hit the
sub button and yeah nonetheless hope you
guys